All right. Welcome to the DDPS seminar everyone. Before we introduce our invited speaker, let's go over some rules and logistics. First of all, please mute yourself during the talk unless you have a sense if you have questions, you're welcome to unmute yourself and ask those questions. Otherwise, please use the chat room to post your questions so that we can address them in q&a session at the end. Second, today's DDPS seminar is open to external audiences. Finally, the talk today will be recorded and uploaded in our YouTube channel. That's about it. Now let me introduce our speaker today. It is an honor to host Professor donburi Sue, who is a professor in the Department of Mathematics of The Ohio State University. He received his PhD degree from division of applied mathematics of Brown University in 2004. He conducted postdoctoral studies in Los Alamos National Laboratory, Princeton University and Brown University before joining the Department of Mathematics of Purdue University as an assistant professor in the fall of 2005. He was promoted to the rank of Associate Professor in 2009, and to full professor in 2012. In 2013, he moved to the University of Utah as a professor in the Department of Mathematics and scientific computing and the Mises Institute. In 2016, he moved to the Ohio State University. He has received NSF career award in 2007, as well as a number of teaching hours at Purdue, he has served on the editorial board of several journals, including Siam Journal of scientific computing, and the Journal of computational physics. He's the founding Associate Editor in Chief of the International Journal for uncertainty quantification, and the founding editor in chief of journal of machine learning for modeling and computing. His research focuses on developing efficient numerical algorithms for uncertainty quantification, stochastic computing and machine learning today, don't Ben will present an exciting, exciting topic, which is data driven modeling of unknown systems with deep neural network. Please enjoy and expect a wonderful talk now without further ado, let me pass the baton to don't begin by asking one random question as usual. Today's random question is What is your favorite season from postseason? Oh, okay. Well, I guess I don't really have a strong preference, but maybe four? Because whether user is lovely, during the four nights in a while? Yes, I'm pretty sure I've been to four. It's always pleasant, I think. Right. All right. Stage is yours. All right. Thank you Dr. Troy, for the for the kind introduction. And also for the for the invite. I'm very happy to be here today to share some of our research in the last few years. As the title says, They said about data driven modeling of unknown system with deep neural networks. So but I would like to make a point throughout my talk that the neural network is deep neural net is a very powerful tool we use, but what we are going to present is fundamentally is a methodology that, in principle, you can use some other techniques, but deep neural net is very, very powerful. I'm a big fan of neural network. So let me start with some motivation. This is preaching to the choir. This is something people many of my friends and colleagues in national labs are very, very familiar with. That's that is how to analyze and predict the behavior of very, very complex system like to just borrow a few slides picture from the web and also some from my colleagues in the past this complex system that is our primary goal for complex for scientific computing. And they have gotten so complex that we need to incorporate many, many physical laws or mathematical models. And most of them have very famous people's name attached to them, because they are very well established mathematical equations to describe and govern with very high fidelity of certain physical phenomena for example, namely stokes equation for basically fluid flow right. And when we deal with very complex system like that, climate will be the ultimate example. And our approach has always been to let's try to incorporate as many equations as possible, as more more physics as possible as a result, and our model eventually gets more and more complex. The point I would like to emphasize here is what I would like to call, we have reached the so called a point of diminishing return. That is, by simply Adding more physics and more equations to the model does not necessary by us too much. Yes, we sometimes we see a little improvement, maybe 10% effect 10% is a lot, sometimes we barely see any. And at the end of the day as model gets at models become more and more time consuming. And we end up with things or this is just random page output from CNN, one of the hurricane forecast models. In fact, there are many, many models here. And I'm sure, as you're all aware of each one of these curves are produced by highly highly sophisticated, computationally expensive models. But at the end of the day, when we have predictions like that, what do we do about them? Is it conceivable even possible that by adding even more equations, introduce more terms in each one of these model? Maybe some of them will converge to the physical truths? To be honest, at this moment, that answer is not that clear, right. So that brings us that short motivation brings us to the topic of so called data driven modeling. And the same message has been made by many researchers in the past few years. That is, it has always been data driven, right. So in the past effect, especially for us, especially people in math department, myself included, that we tend to think of model as nice equation, but we sometimes forget why where are the equations came from in the first place, they came from, not long time, observations sometimes take decades or even centuries of observation. And at some points on smart breeding, the mind came into play, and they came up with nice equations, of course, named after them. And then we use this equation, these are the models we are familiar with, to predict and analyze the behavior of the system. Of course, what we have already accepted that we are not able to solve all the equations, these are simple enough. But most models, mathematical models we have today are so complicated. That's why we use computer. That's the whole discipline of scientific computing. And so this would, I will argue, these days, when we talk to the model, the real model is, in fact, a piece of computer code is a software. And it's after all are this with holidays of the mathema, no matter how beautiful the equations are, we still need to deal with them, we need to approximate them. And maybe along the way, we even introduce a bug here and there in our computer code. But essentially, at the end of the day, what's inside the computer is what we have to rely upon to predict and analyze the underlying physics. So the whole idea of data driven model is that, upon realizing this path, we can use computer to help us solve the equation. And realizing again, our brain is not sufficient, large enough to come up with a nice equation. Why don't we take this all the way, let's come from data, let's just use the data to drive somehow get a piece of software, and that as a model that we can execute. And eventually, let's just use this model to predict and analyze the underlying physics. So that's the whole idea of data driven more than just to bypass human as much as possible. So having said all that, let me be a little bit more concrete, about what I want to talk about in this about our research here, the data driven modeling. So our focus is both basically on dynamical system. So let's assume that I we have time history of data, this will call this trajectory of data over certain time intervals, we can have many, many of them. And we don't don't know that the laws behind the dynamics, we do not have the governing equation, if we do have the equation that by all means go ahead and solve them. What we want to do is that using this trajectory data, the time history, to come up with a sort of recursive model, that we can march forward and predict this will be the model prediction, the truth evaluate, evaluate, at the same time, this is the truth such that our model prediction is the numerical model is approximation will be a very good approximation to the physical truth. Now, if we have this model is as if we have the equation we can discretize it, and is this without the equation, but we never will. We're not we're not really in most cases can we cannot write down that mathematical reason. But we do have this numerical scheme that can accomplish what we want to do, which is prediction of the future. So here we're talking about prediction. I want to make a few very important remarks. Two of them are very important one is that and I will emphasize in the next slides as well, we even though the time is the data we have had time in there, we will by all means do not we do not want to incorporate the time as an input variable. And that is we try not to approximate x as a function of time. Why the reason is simple. If we try to approximate a function as x a function of time, this will be our training data or what we see and yes, we pay Based on this, we can come up with a nice medication nice approximation of x of t. But our goal is prediction the prediction will go way beyond whatever we have observed in our training data. And so, if our approximate are coming from this, we will always be extrapolating beyond what we observe, no method is reliable when we extrapolate. So that's the point I want to make that we will never try to think of x as function time as conversely, here, we only think of x as a progressive recursive iteration over time. So time will now come into play a second what we observe x may not be the entire complete set of variables in the system. So we do not know the system equation. But to make matters worse, we may not be able to observe observe everything again, climate may be the ultimate example we can measure, you know, wind pressure, pressure temperature, as a few variables. But the entire climate system may that if there is a closed mathematic model, we may involve, let's say 10,000 variables, we do not have that we can only measure a field. So this is a very big challenge. That's also something we try to observe, we try to tackle what if what we observe the dynamics data is only a small subset of the entire system, which we don't have the equation in the first place. So, having said that, let me come back to the part of we do not want time variable in this. So this will be an example for the methodology I will describe in a moment, we only need short bursts of trajectory data time history data. So you can take the so this will be example of I say I need eight points along time history. So you can pull this out from a single long measurement data fine, you can put for multiple pieces here, you and it doesn't really matter what it is. So at the end of the day, we're going to collect them into a set of measurement of length eight, let's call this our training data, and you can collect the recipe 10,000. Many of them, if you have long treasure, the treasure data, time history, you can throw a lot of segments out of these things. So we would prefer them to be from different trajectories. But that's important. And yet mine secondary concern, the most important thing that we watch, next thing we do, we will remove the time variable, a simple thing, we just dropped them. Alright, so by dropping down, we will not know when exactly this trajectory occurred in time, as opposed to goes in here. All we see are the segments of trajectory time series of eight entries. And they are the AutoCorrect a different time doesn't really matter to us, all we carry that we only have each one of them is as as if they start with the initial condition and the mask forward seven times that all we care. So by doing so we will remove the time variable. Also, it makes that acquisition collection much easier, you don't need to record the time, you just need to record that a relative time. So that's what we do here. That's, in fact a very easy thing to accomplish. Having said that, let me give the example how this can come into play. So this will be very similar to what I just illustrated earlier. Suppose I have time history, this will be example of so called glucose induced insulin oscillation, which is, as many of you may be aware of very relevant to a diabetes study. Let's assume that we have measurements of insulin response after injection for certain individual, I have exactly zero to 1516 points, I do not care about time, there's only 16 points separated by times that point oh five certain unit, I don't do not know exactly what time they say. But this is only second point after initial points. And also I have this response at certain so called baseline glucose level is a single constant parameter. Every individual have a glucose level for me sitting here I have a glucose level yet have a meal, my glucose level would be different at different level, if I go on exercise, this number will be different is the constant is an integral constant. Let's just say we can collect this kind of data at a different glucose level. After injection, the short time response offense again, zero to 15, only 16 points of this time time step. Let's say we can collect many of them. Okay. And it turns out people can collect a lot of data about diabetes. But let's assume this is the only thing we have. We only have at the different parameters, baseline glucose parameter level, I have the early response of insulin, we ask the questions, can we build the model and understand the very long time behavior of this incident? What what happened after this early stage? So that's what we're going to do. So let's try to do a data driven thing. We don't do not have an equation for that. So what are we based on? What do we have, I'm gonna use a neural network. And at the input, I'm gonna throw this single parameter into one node. And for the measurement that are from zero to 15, I'm gonna throw the zero to 14 to the early nodes. So I have, this will be 15 plus one second inputs, I will use a very last one, as we enforce the output, that's why we compute the mean square error to match the output to the 15th. The last entry of my measurement data in between well connect, very simple, fully connected, feed forward network. So and then we have all this data. And you do it on your own as Trini. I'm sure many of you are familiar how this goes to a mini batch optimization. So this in TensorFlow, or pytorch. At the end of the day, once we've enforced this main square loss to a certain level, we call this method Converse. Alright, so this is what we then we have new annatto create a model, this model with the given initial parameter t zero, given zero to 14 input, I can recursive go forward in time get 15 then I can move 15 Here, a slide everything backward, and I can get sick thing I can recursively go forward in time for as long as I want to. So this will continue me a long time behavior of incident, but the difference that we have now created a data driven sort of a scalar model that doesn't require knowledge of any other variables that are involved in this as what you can imagine a very complex math biology problem. So the question is that we can always turn that we'll get the model the question how good this is. So let's do some validation and plot a few others initial structure zero to 15. same setting as before, at a different glucose level is one and we're gonna feed them into the network neural network model we just created is the one model we created we'll never touch it again we only execute on the different certain days. So, let's feed this initial one a correspond to T 010 Put this into initial condition, Mars is for entire form much longer time this was the result we get everything of the circle the circle would be what we feed into the network everything afterwards would be the prediction by network itself. As you can see the network prediction will be the blue very close to the truth I will tell you in a moment what truth is, you can see the agreement is quite well and is reached steady state which is obviously not very obvious from what we can observe from the initial evolution right this goes to set the state take another current 1.1 And the system again after initial condition the predicted by the network itself go again goes to steady state with some observation earlier pick another curve and yes again steady state and then also the US citizen become a little more obvious at early stage another curve 1.3 All the sudden the neuronode process is a periodic state which is much the troops and again everything of a circle is pure prediction no data anymore and make a different G zero level these become even bigger oscillations alright. So and you can see the math with the so called truce here is very very close. And now that we have this scalar model for single variable incident for his longtime dynamic we can analyze that and now we see this accurate enough I can play god mode, we can just simply interrogate this model get all kinds of behavior out of it one thing people study in this phenomena is that people already know that G zero is the single parameter please plays a key role in determining the long term behavior of system so in here is a steady state and here is the periodic states. So, what we people do is that they just record the max and mean of the when the system reached a stable state. Now here maximum would be a same number here maximum will be above here means here and you plot this max the mean against the single parameter you get this kind of bifurcation diagram, when G zero is quite small, we have a steady state max and the match each other and when t zeros past certain threshold, it become a periodic state and the amplitudes become bigger and bigger and bigger and all of a sudden passing here the system return to the steady state again. So it's quite interesting behavior. Once again this up blue curve blue dots are produced by just interrogating this neural network model and the reality the truth okay. So, we can also do things like with different GCL single parameter and the system will respond with different than if I have a meal my G zero will be at a different level, the response will would be different if have another dessert and much easier, cast higher and high. Anyway, this is this This can result people invested in the literature. So having a Once again, you can see here the neural net model has very remarkable accuracy compared to the truth. And what is the truth here, we don't really have real data, the truth in our case, is produced by synthetic data coming from this. So the whole thing is about incident response is in some very complex math biology system, I wish I had no idea about what we did. There are several models to study this incident response. So we pull this one from one well established textbook is reasonably complex with this bifurcation behavior. These are the two models we use, and has four state variables, and about 16 parameters. We put all the parameters around the book, everything you standard from textbook, what we did we solve this system with these parameters with MATLAB with accuracy. But we record for network purpose, we record only two things, why is z z, this g zero the single parameter in our modeling. The other one is the early response of I, zero to 15, the first second entries of the response, everything else from the model, we throw them away, they are never recorded, as if we don't know. So this is just pretend. In the real world, we can only measure this and the early response of this. Based on this little thing you can see the neuronal can build the model that analyze a long time behave of AI without any knowledge of any other variables whatsoever. Okay, the reintroduction everything, you'd basically as if I have no idea how there's physics involved, what's variable involved, I just What do I see and what we model that's so, I hope by this by this example, at least is so so that the you know, you suggest that it is possible now that we can build very accurate the model and closed by itself. And this closed method system closed, this closed system, right, everything defined each other, but self closed for only a subset of variable, which in this case, there is not a single mathematical model to government evolution by we have to rely on other variables. For the data driven modeling. It doesn't require that. So having said that, like I said, when we have this data, we throw them into a network is not a random choice we made. In fact, this work was a result of several about four or five years development over the over this year when in fact, the example is in none of these papers. When we try the example, we actually no there is no way it does not wait has to work, it turns out to be a one of the easiest example to train and to get high accuracy. So so this is what I want to talk to you about the so called method, so called Flow Map learning, I just call this F ml, and how it works. And how it makes gets us to the modeling of the software only a single variable in a much, much bigger system. So again, this is setting. So just 10 seconds of neural network, we do not require any special uses of any special structure of neural network, all we use that neural network does, at the end of the day is a mapping from input to output. In this case, we input the map to H R H to four variables R four. And in between more almost all our works, we simply use fully connected feed forward network with nothing special user usual ReLU activation function. And sometimes we use tan h, we didn't use any of these nets turns out there's no need for any other special network. So let me come back to the basic setting. So now, let's let me start with a simpler system. Simple problem. That is I have a dynamic system that we do not know, the governing equation, right, so but we do have observation of x. So we observe every variable in the system. So this will be the evolution of x. And again, from that time history will prove us trajectory out of this. That's our training data. It's a very, very busy field of so called data driven equation recovery. That is where the measurement time has of x let's try to recover. If we do not do that, in fact, we have equals, we have some early work on that as well. In this work we do and try to recover f at the point being that you want to recover F with some error. I mean as loss most likely is nonlinear, we still need to discretize it and make it into a computer code algorithm. So here let's not try to do that. Let's again like I said let's do the one shot we want create a model directory in one step. So we try to approximate the underlying flow map. That's why where the name came from for the method, what is flow map flow map is simple concept in dynamical system is simply the mapping between solutions at one stage t zero can be any time to another state t. So this is the mapping with parameters I would like to see something something admin right to ensue, need admin rights, I just click as x as anyway, hopefully I don't talk anyway. So the mapping is just an empty map solution from one time to another time for autonomous system like this, only time difference matters, that's key things with time doesn't really matter. So let's to look at any is any solution from data from one instance to the next. And they're all separate, let's assume the timestamp is constant delta delta t. So the mapping, this promo is simply x map to the current time to the next stage. Right. So that's governed by exactly same map covers by the same parameter, which if we assume constant, this doesn't even matter here. So this is simply map from RT to RT. And that's what we can do with any mapping. So in this case, we only need the two data from any trajectory. So a you can pull a pair consecutive pair anywhere from time page to pull them out. Alright, so then I will just call these the first 1x. One, the second one is x to the all relative, again, time doesn't matter is only relevant relative position, everywhere case, x 1x 2x. When its current state solution, x two is the next one step later. And this is branch wide by this map, which are the two are the the concept becomes, we want fun rd to rd, let's try to minimize this error. So I will find a map approximate approximate amount to this such that my output by my mapping would try to match the real thing. As much as possible mean square loss, you minimize this problem is risk like everything like the non easterly LeaseWeb problem, there's nothing fancy to that, once we find this mapping, and you can now execute given any x one, you can keep recursing of going forward in time. And that will give you predicts for a long, long time is the d dimensional function. approximator is not operator learning. That's a key thing. Why because you only care about the function from rd to R, the output D doesn't really matter. But as I said, it's not operator learning, which is a busy topic these days is simply because again, the fact that I said we did not ever ever try to write x as fans of TF have little T inside and become an operator. But now we only look x as a vector. So it's multi dimensional coordinate is a function approximation for low dimensional can to polynomial Gaussian process everything. In fact, if it is reasonable or small, I will just say by all means go with potty mouth, it kills the problem with extraordinary high accuracy. That's our words, in fact, our first paper on this, but most likely, in practice, it is not very small. So new anatomy is essential, very, very powerful. So this is how it works. Again, we are if you insist, we also advocates use neural network. And then of course, the network output, which is minimize this error. This is very simple, fully connected, feed forward, this will be our friend. And you can also do RESNA, which in our first paper we advocate of doing that the retina is simply says this mapping, it just doesn't try to map from input to output. In fact, this part is mapped to the difference. And as a result, we took prediction, you have to add this back on you can then that will be the scheme that's the only difference between these two, they are absolutely equivalent, mathematically, there's no difference is plus minus one, depending on where you put them. But this ResNet structure looks like all of our stepping, except it is not auto forward. That in fact, the entire error here has nothing to do with delta t so this exact integral in time, there's no temporal error, no explicit dependency on delta t the other errors basically meet the minimization of the training error. So, in our early work, we had used ResNet primarily to wish I found this computationally advantageous, but as we gain more and more experience, we have found that that you know, this thing will requires very high accuracy at the end of the day, whereas that doesn't really matter. So you use your choice whether you use them use it or not. We still keep residents in most of our work is just mostly for from the legacy code. Alright, so let me show you one example. Again, this example has is a four dimensional example. So my status variable u one u two, V one v two to sort of OD, two algebraic constraint, there's not really od right. So, the mapping as I said will be art for to our four is reasonably low dimension. Let's do in fact this result is produced by polynomial it will not work a similar result. Alright, so, and this the producer of the 1000 steps. Again, the training data is just one separated by one step you see extraordinary short time phase which is one step right And I want to make a again, an effort is that upon you that you look at this function, the V tool response, and v one as well, as a function of time, this extraordinary difficult function to approximate with a spikes like this, there's always no method that can really approximate these kinds of spikes with high accuracy theory, it is very accurate. Why? Because once again, as I said at the very beginning, we never try to approximate x as a function of time, we only try to approximate X, how it evolved over one step as a function, right? So once you get every one step correct, it is eventually will produce the correct function over time. This is exactly how anytime integrator Max works. If you knew the equation, you can solve this by rune Dakota known score that looks exactly like that, except n is well defined from the equation, you know what this is here, we just don't know what the end is, we use data to try to learn this. But the time server allows us to go progressively in time, accurately every step, and eventually it can produce some vastly compressed behavior over time. But the function this thing as function of time never come into play. So that's the, again, the message I think I'm overstating a little bit. But again, this is the key feature of this method. Alright. So now let's move on to the very practical situation, that in most cases, we cannot measure every variables in the entire system. So now, let's have the whatever come autonomous system, there's a big complexity that we don't know the equation, we have no idea what the f is. So when in fact, we probably don't even have idea how many axes variables, we need to have this just, we have no idea. But we do have is that we can measure a few a subset of them. So Z, like I said, in the climate modeling, this can be temperature can be pressure can be dense, then stay on a few things. And everything else who are the missing variables, we may not even know how many were missing. Is it 550 5000 10,000? Missing? We have no idea because we don't know what the complete system look like. But we have let's say you you measure three variables? That's all we have the question we ask based on time, which of these three variables? Can we build a model for these three variables only, in principle, coming from autonomous system, is it possible there's a so called very well known mores wanting the formula says, you know, this kind of equation does exist, in principle is not useful, because you start the equation look like this, this is my COVID term, this some integral term. And that's initial condition, we don't know usually treat it as a random variable. So this is not important. What's not useful is that this formula is exact formula, but it's only sort of like existence, it doesn't tell us how to get our how to get in most important is k, the kernel thing. And so there has been a lot work on estimating approximating kernel k from here, but that's based on the knowledge we know the letter F in the first place, we are trying to get to K. But here, we do not know this anyway, so there's no way we can have cake. But nonetheless, we're going to use this as a motivation to design our data driven approach. Alright, so the motivation goes goes like this, you look at this integral. So if we want to know any the evolution of the the observables, that count the time, let's call this T, this needs to go back from as far as equals zero with Tina minus that it will be content T, S goes to t, this T month you will be zero. So this requires us to know the solution at the current time, go all the way back to the initial condition, we're going to make a very mild assumption that he has these so called a memory memory that can go very long in most system, so we only need to go back from the current time to some fixed time. Alright, so you do not need to know your solution today or tomorrow. You do not need to know everything has happened through the beginning of the universe, in fact, in most cases will go back to a certain amount of time, that's enough. Anything further back in in history, do not have any impact on the current state. That's the final memory assumption, which is almost universally true for any system. And of course, the difference is that the key that How long should we go back? And we don't know. But that's problem dependent. But let's assume we can, we should only go back from here, back towards final time. That's how we go. Alright, so now this integral is replaced by this with some negligible error. That's the first mild assumptions. Now that we change this to a final integral that doesn't depends on t anymore. We're just gonna assume before final integral, we can we have some kind of approximation method that can compute this number very accurately based on small thresholds based on whatever data in between these two in between count the time to backtrack, the memory time. This again is easy, because if we know the equation, we can simply do some kind of gross quadrature. This will be this exists here, of course, we do not know the integral part, we always say, you know what a good approximation exists, that's all we need. Alright, having said both now we say we exchange this to approximate formulations that if we let's call the current time t, n, if we want to know that you've always had current on tn, we just need to know this a TN and this entire Indigo depends on everything to backtrack one step two step, whatever number of steps that content in the memory. That's how we do. So this is our approach discrete approximation to the mores once the equation based on very mild assumption, and this just tells us, we just need to find this and this, but we don't have this. That's what we do with data driven, we just said, our model says, in order to know one step in the future, all we need is the current time step and something go back in time, we need data on this. And we'll see if we can create this mapping, that's the model. So the function approximation become that given this metadata, so this will be n plus one times d, that data to this mapping, this will be our mapping, we want to fund this. And this will be the network structure if we want to do so find this operator. And this will be example says I only need to go back to step in memory, this is the current, this is the future, if we go with one and two. And if you have data, if you have enough data of three map to one, you have data lands, at least four in your time history, you can create input and output. And you can have many of these you turn network that will be the model. And the model is in fact, coming from very rigorous derivation. So as I said, here, this is relationship here has nothing to do with neural networks, neural network is just a way to try to create this operator. And so anyway, so this will be the example I showed you earlier, like the instant example goes from zero to 14, and with a one parameter here, and to the next. Right, so. So that neural network model of the training doesn't doesn't really give us more research on these methods, eventually, it doesn't give it just give us a direct predictive model that we can go forward in time. How does this compare to the more is the one that we don't know, in fact, as we're not even trying to recover more is wanting in this case. So let me show an example a linear system equations. Linear squares turns out to be quite difficult to model. It's x dot equals a x, let's say I have 20 vector of 20. A is a 20 by 20 matrix, we come up with some random choice of these A, we can solve them. With our synthetic data, we assume we don't know anything about 10 component, we have short time measurement countries are the first 10 component of x, we know nothing about the 400 parameter in this system, we know nothing about the missing 10 variables. And in fact that now you can see that the 10 variables here, do not give us a closed system to solve always requires not as a cue. Alright, so I will contest in this case, how long is the memory, when we create a memory when you plan to six, let's call this second. So it's very short trajectory we need we just need to see many, many pieces of this we create a mapping and then we were going to execute for the prediction of x one to 10 forward in time to go all the way from zero to 150. A very long time prediction, this will be the x three this will be the x six. Alright, so as you can see the neural net model, which is rare compared to the truth by solving the entire system, and is very, very close after this long time in a non tuba dynamic. So it's not steady state is not purely to Radek state is unclear what state is, but anyway, the accuracy is good. Let's make this slightly slightly nonlinear. So let's deal with not very chaotic but not very chaotic. It's a fast slow variable. So the x 123 Are the slow variables. And why the fast well how fast is it depends on how small epsilon is. We assume that we can measure slower but in most cases, that's where you can fast variable too fast, we cannot measure. So based on that complex data x 123. We want to create a model for the slow variables only. So this is like coarse graining homogenization you name it that we always try to come up with an effective model for the slow variables, the course variables. In this particular case, we're going to homogenize this mathematical formalization. Just get rid of this and that's the mathematical model, which is exactly when epsilon go to zero, right. So you Here, let's fix the case apps X absolutely is point one. So it's not exactly this not very accurate, but it's reasonably good. At the same time, we can use measurement data 123, left neural network create a model for x 123. You know how much the model, and this will be the prediction accuracy, this prediction of x one, from zero to 200 to 400, I did not plot the first 200, because if I do that, everything cluttered looks like random noise. But upon cloud zoo, if we zoom in, they're not random noise that determines chaotic system. So the first 200 is probably the entire is missing, the memory is 1.2. That's the math 20 Do we have, we just need the data of x 123 of lens 1.2. This prediction up to 400, you can see neural network is a read the Choose computing from the real system. And synthetic data is the black you can see the red and black check each other really, really, really, really well. And the blue, which is a human created, homogeneous system, you know, human approximate is not too bad. But you can visually visually see the difference compared to the truth. If we compute the error over lambda, this will be the error by our human model human created model. So that now is from zero to 400. These are typical error behavior girls over time, nothing surprising this error by the machine learning close model by neural network, the error is a lot smaller and a lot more stable, we do not have a full understanding of the runtime stability behavior of these neural net models, just because we don't have enough mathematical tools to understand your network. But we have seen this kind of behavior very, very often it's the longtime behavior stability can often be surprised, surprising, but in a very pleasant way. So let's make this fully chaotic. So it's nice as much smaller system. Let's look at Lauren 63. So this will be the exact Lauren system through which we generate synthetic data and validation data. And we tried to model only x that we only have x as a data, we create a scalar model for x. But here I will show you x and y because x and y I can plot in a two dimensional plot. So let's pretend here we have recorded time series of x and y only, but we know nothing about Z. Right? So this so based on x and y, we're gonna use neural net to this flow map learning to create a model for x and y only. And is we need a history, the history is point one times that point o one. So this requires to have 10 step of measurement data x and y, this will be the school dimensional the deep neural network model the face portrait, it starts from here, this is up to 100. In fact, I think it is more than 100 Maybe 1000. I forgot. But anyways, long time integrins was and this will be the exact model. But the Phase project would project on excellent why the truce, you can see visually This is very good. We don't have good point wise error is chaotic system, nothing would track the Pontoise error accurately over on time, it's just nature of chaotic system. So here we just look visually, they look qualitative, qualitatively, they're close enough. We also based on this data, we computed a few measure for the how chaotic the system is the so called correlation dimension, approximate entropy layout, no exponent is a number from the neural network model these are choose, you can see that the number of reasonably close I mean, they're not super, super close, but they're reasonable. Turns out these numbers very hard to get stable number this really depends on how many entries you have in the, in the in your time history is very sensitive to that. So but anyway, we think this these are very, very reasonably good match. Let's make the system bigger, this low res 96, which has 40x, or x goes state variable has x 240. We only record x 123. And we use neural network to record to produce a three dimensional model. The history again is point one. So when you're 10 Step pong with hands up ping pong oh one. This is a three dimensional Phase project up to 500 very long time the integration. And this is the 40 dimensional model project in three dimension. This is now it gets messier is unclear what this looks like. But anyway, this looks reasonable. And then we compute this chaotic measure, they all look reasonable close some numbers very closer. And the invariant measure that distribution that's upon steady state. Again, they look fairly reasonable across right. So this is chaotic. So let me give you a short summary. What we did here that when we don't have a dynamical system, that's okay is it first if we can measure we have time because of all the variables is a simple case, you just create a one step mapping. Your training data is only one Two steps. And you can get her out of it, even though in most nuanced funny when you're 10,000 20,000 History trends, but this 10,001 is out of one step that so the overall data requirement is in fact very low thinking about the up to one system prediction sometimes services and you can easily go 1 million steps that you can pull off a two step data from here. This is what it looked like. If, however, what's your data is only a partial measurement, then that requires memory, and then this will be the mapping, and you have more terms on the left, alright, in both cases, we advocate the use of neural network because the dimension would be high. Keep in mind here, for example, here with two step memories, three dimension, but each z is a vector, if z is a vector of 10, this is 30 dimension. So dimension goes high very fast. So and as I show you several examples, it looks really, really well, we just make a quick remark that you can also model system with different controls. And all excitations, the key of this, there are some modifications had to go into there. But at the end of the day, you can do, you can train your neural network model based on some control, then the prediction that come to can be entirely different that's never ever present in alternative data. So this is a very remarkable property, we have found this from this thing, by looking at one step at a time never have time involved, that allows us to do that. So this paper has a detail on that. So I don't have time on this, I want to give you a note, just a few minutes, a quick idea on how we do this with PDE. Because we have discussed so much about dynamic system. PDE is what people really care about. So now it's a similar setting. Suppose I have a set of grid on which I have data. So the data is my ID, now it's a field. So they say I can think of my observation as one vector field as if this is a finite element solver, your grid, your grid will be a vector of length, let's say 10,000. If you have 10,000, know that you have an atom solver. So it's a one big vector. Suppose the autonomous suppose we observe every view, and now it's fully observed system, it's just like od upon this with holidays, oh, the PDS OD. And is, nothing is missing. So we just need to map from current state to one step later you have this, we can create a map, we can solve this, learn this unknown PDE. Right? Players, it doesn't really work. We try this many, many times, no less than 1000 different cases, it just didn't work. Why is because in dynamic system, the mapping between this other state variable x, x such as vectors, they're components of vector. Nothing we can say about this, the dynamic system for PD is different, they use our solution in space, they are not random components of a vector u has smoothness and regularity, they are connected in through them, because PD has operator in them. So there's a smoothness regularity in there that we are not enforcing here does know things. When I say they don't work, they don't really not work, they just work sort of inconsistently. And without the high accuracy of Sony without this work, we really demand accuracy to be high. So we eventually filed convolution network still didn't quite work. Again, no less than a few 1000 test cases still didn't quite work. So we eventually were forced to develop for the first time. And that was structure to enforce something. Again, it was it is motivated by the mathematics. So suppose I have a PDE like this involves some kind of differential operator, I don't know what they are, I don't know what else is I don't how many, but I suppose I know the PDE. And suppose I have a set of grid. And I can solve it by some kind of order for I'm not going to do that. But all of our does exist, right. So once that mapping from here, this will be my operator, and each derivative would be replaced by some differentiation matrix that numerical analysis helps. That is everything linear matrix vector product for derivatives, this would be my very naive old iPhone, it stability would most likely be an issue but we're not solving we just need this to be on a conceptual, conceptual level, it exists, it gives me a some kind of truncation error, one step. And we'll just say that since we don't know this, we don't know the derivative, I would just say, you know, what we can make every differentiate some matrix, a nonlinear vector, the operator, it doesn't even need to be linear operators, if I make everything linear nonlinear is incorporate this as a special case. So so the existence all of our cells that exist even bigger class and nonlinear scheme, such that my error once Deborah could be at least could be smaller, it at worst will be like this. So it's a special thing. Just we're just making this class of method. Start now neither all of a much bigger much broader and we are saying that the arrow will commit or One Step most likely will be smaller than this, but at worst case will be just like this. Why? Because I can simply put these back into my linear matrix. that exists. So that's all we need. So, these are when we say this nonlinear or forward method does exist like this with some of the we don't know, and this this operator correspond to L. This is how we design our neural network structure, the input, once that input the vector, our fan atom in the grid is here, the output is here, in between we have a certain neural network in power goes for it this way, in parallel in this direction, each one corresponds some can nonlinear operate with that we do not know. And then I have another network, horizontal here acting component wise against all of them. This is no need operator here to learn the L here. And if we connect these together, that I can train, and this one works consistently. In fact, without this layer, what we call assembly layer up to here these days is resembles convolutional very much. Alright, so this is the key. This is what we call the Decembrie block. The assembler layer is what really makes everything worse to enforce regularity and things like that. Let me quickly show you a few examples. Again, the equation here only serve the purpose of generating training data and validation data. So the equation may be simple. UT plus u x equals zero, the simplest equation analytically, perhaps the most difficult one to solve accurately numerically, again, everything here just read out one step vector. Here, we have 50 nos, you will be the vector of 50 to 50 mapping. So there's nothing missing just one step mapping in between how that assembly assembly block. And this will be, you know, predicted over a fairly long time that 20 to one, you can see the accuracy quite well. In fact, the dispersion error is much much better than we expected many numerical method if you know, we know the equation to solve this by some standard numerical method as to what it was so worth this personnel. But he or he just by learning, then equation isn't the ration diffusion doesn't really matter. I'll just want to show you that it works with now uniform grid in this case that the grid is not only non uniform, they also randomly permute it within this matter doesn't require any knowledge of the physical structure of the grid, that geometric structure connection is not required, you can deal with higher density or this easier case, because in more diffusive diffuse equations, I'll be easy to simulate integral equation which if I can make the effective make this non local problem again, is diffusive. So it's very easy accuracy is good. For this equation, you will be an interesting example, that again, in this case, when we generate the training sample, we have 50 nodes, we solve this by some we actually don't, at the beginning, we only we solve this analytically, that means that our our training, data is created by some random like Fourier series sine cosine, we created their their finest theory so that they are very smooth, we solve this by one cons that we support a 102 Nothing happened or one times a no shocks whatsoever. So that's our 20 that also need a small sine, cosine, or one steps, which is also similar sine cosine. Upon learning the operator mapping between the two steps, if you execute this on the new initial condition over a much longer time, when it will appear, it does appear. So that's the thing I would like to emphasize here again, is we do not need to see the physics in order to predict the phasing into in a very, if you recall, in the very first instant example this already showed up. Now one of the early stage, the incident response has studied the periodic state, you'll never see that internal data. But over long term, if you have the correct model, you will produce the correct physics and the physics is always a very short time dynamic, it doesn't have any interesting fits in the short term, you all ones up almost nothing happens. To make matters a little more interesting here, we assume that we can only observe grid value add right half in fact 40% of the domain and in this case, we actually do need to use memory because these are 50 vector or 50 or we only observe 20 of them. So a missing 30 component is missing variable we have memory, but with sufficient memory, you can still predict fizzy in here and this accuracy isn't that high, but we say You know what, in this case with shock and 40% domain you know, I will give this a pass. So, let me just finish continue to dimension and unstructured grid, there will be two dimension but this PD but the entire is one set of variable completely wiped out we only have data v this very expensive, this is like 50 by 50 grid. So the vector will be 2500 length. With memory I believe we have 10 memory. So this will be 25,000 input for neural network. So it's a little bit expensive, but long term prediction the solution go is up down sort of sort of periodic with a little bit diffusion. And you can see the reference prediction looks fairly reasonable. So anyway, let me finish time is up. What I've discovered what I call the F L, the flow Macron is a method, or it's a methodology, again, I want to emphasize is not, it shows some capability that was never really, we didn't really thought about before. For example, if we can model only things we observe, so this will be very useful, if we try to do some kind of multiscale modeling or try to speed up competition by only predicting the cost variables, we suppose faster, or you just planned this, I only see this a model is right. So without worrying about any other variables that may or may not coupled with the things we want model. But this capability is new in certain way. Like I hope this talk has illustrate for you that it's not because they knew and that is simply because we set up the problem mathematically correctly. And we set it up as correct mapping from input output neuron that is a very powerful to one, which I've a big fan fan of, but it's not what brings the magic, the magic is about setting it up properly. And in most cases, our network is very small. It's not really deep learning like this is not very deep. But anyway, there's no really need to use special structure. The thing was memory, a one they asked some of you may ask, can you famous network structure that incorporate memories? LSTM? Can you do that? Yes, if you are missing variable, if you do LSDM, you can accomplish about the same result. We have our collaborator who has tested this software extensively. But then the is back of the question. In our case, if we know how it works, why do you need to introduce this structure with a gate and everything? You know, it's a small plane network with Candida. So anyway, one big thing I would emphasize is that, and for many of you who have done your last funding, who really high on the accuracy of things, you know how hard it is to reproduce. The result is for students who are trained that when you try now, today, tomorrow, you may or may not be the same, you'll put a code from GitHub from somebody paper, and you will try to replicate the result you cannot, whose fault it is. So in our group, reproduce, the reproducibility is the number one criteria, good results or bad results better be reproducible. So almost, we're in the process of organizing almost all the example I discussed here in this talk and many of our papers, to put them online, including the training that how to generate a synthetic training training data set. In fact, the training data set we used to just generate example, more importantly, we're going to put the data we used to plot the plots, so that you can reproduce what we had in paper immediately and then compare to your results. So I'm also in the process of writing a very detailed paper describing the computational details, the arts, how to create reproducible plots. So anyway, all of this will be available is in the process of getting uploaded at the moment, I have a new website that I use in the making. But anyway, this will come up in just a few weeks. So with this, I will finish and take some questions. Thank you. Thank you so much. Thanks again, for the wonderful talk. I enjoyed it a lot. I'm sure everyone else enjoyed it a lot as well. Although it's 11. How, let's have a q&a session. Don't be I hope you have some time. I do have some time. So I don't know how to see chat. Yeah, well, don't worry about it. Okay. So, Pat, are you there? Or are you still there? Um, you posted a lot of questions. And and yeah, just let let me let's just take the most important ones. Yeah. There are other questions to that from other people. So. So you seem to be assuming that, that neural nets are the way to go here rather than trying to discover the equations themselves in some interval form. And there has been a lot of work for decades on that approach. So could you? I mean, of course, there's also been a lot of recent work on on using neural nets to do similar kinds of things, because could you just talk about the pros and cons, and why you think that this is doesn't have to be better? Right? This could be just one among many approaches. But you did suggest at times that you thought this would be better than other approaches, including implicitly better than learning the equations directly. What's your opinion on this? So yeah, so I do. I didn't say that. Your neck was very powerful. Again, like I said in this but you don't have to do it on network. So you want that in, in all these things we did here. It's just a tool to to accomplish this kind of mapping so it just a way to accomplish It's mapping. Like I said, if the dimension is low for novel cures, polymer is the king. But I am a fan of neural network because many of cases the dimensions very high the input the nodes. And so let's do new. And so I, why do you believe that neural nets will be better than say, trying to discover the, the equations in classic od form. So that's a that's had nothing to do so again, is I want to be very clear, is I will advocate in getting this off model neuron that can be part of our community, as opposed of discount F in it. So we have done similar things. So let's say you want discover F. So let's just assume you can discover F analytically Correct. All right now. I'm talking about inducing it from the data in the same way you are with a neural net. Yes, that's why I'm saying that if you can induce F from data, first of all, you can never induce F, exactly correct. You have error in the first place, right? Then you have the D squared as whatever the approximate f to start with, you induce another error. So error compound on itself, you're solving the wrong, you're solving sort of slightly the wrong equation in the first place. So just to be clear, are you saying that, forget about whether you do in neural nets, I it sounded as though you rather than learning a differential equation where a difference equation, whether it's in neural net or other form, that you're learning, mapping directly from those values at one time step to the next time step, you're not learning the difference? You're learning. My point is, regardless where you're where you come from, you can try to use your data to recover F to the other form. At the end of the day, your prediction look like this. One step to the next is a mapping. So that's what we just tried to go to this one start mapping in one shot, because I believe one shot there because it's overloaded. It's nice, I have data, I want to create this one step mapping in one step, that's all. And as opposed to separate the tasks, you will introduce error in different stages, they compound on each other make their way, days and plus Y equals X some kind of execute, we should follow up separately. I've got I got your email address. Someone else had a question about noise? Noise. Very good question noise. There are two kinds of noise. Why is the standard measurement or if folks in this slide, if I have x 1x, two, both have observation noise, this is easier to deal with in the sense that you just steal because at the end of the day, the learning part of the things I discussed here is really about minimizing the mean square error. So let's just do this. Yeah, so it's about minimizing the mean squared error. So we know is that the square is sort of robust against noise, well use the accuracy not so accuracy. So have you have you added noise to synthetic data and shown we have our paper I only showed you here without noise because one, so the accuracy that is fundamental understanding. So in some people, we do have a noisy data example, the lack of accuracy will be less as expected nothing to that. So. But there are other things we do not fully understand some. So the other type of noise would be if your equation has stochastic synth driving it that that will become St. That's an entire different things that we have less understanding. We won't have the very first paper just recently wrapped up. I'm not ready to discuss that extensively yet. We have some understanding, but we have struggled with st for quite a long time. So okay. You said it early in the talk. You said, let me see what you were, you were talking about. Not having time as part of the learned. That's and I thought you meant by that, that you were simply making the Markov assumption that you did not have memory, but then later you introduced memory. So I figured that I misunderstood you. What did you What did you mean in the early comment? What was I meant is that which so which is what's the bet? What I meant is it for example, if this is a new one, so let's look this up my input x and x, so we should never have t as explicit info. So for example, I do not want to measure x as a function of t I should never have t as a node in here. Okay. Yeah. And that's not the same as making the Markov assumption that's not that's not okay it's it's the if you make market assumption that's true but it's weaker than that but they're all Markov right so anyway, just how memory is not is not a not making the Markov assumption depends on how you find mark over this one's DeMarco multistep Markov. So Oh, I see. Yeah, okay. Yeah. Fine, but so, yes, well, I think I think I think I don't that's not controversial. I just, I understand now what you're looking at. Yeah, okay. And I and go ahead if there's any others there were definitely some others down below. Yeah, well, I want to invite the Rob Hayes. He asked about the newest data. But he also, he also asked on other questions. So Rob, if you want to unmute yourself and ask your questions directly, that would be very helpful. So it came down to the look like the process you're describing does require each successive data point to have the same time step. So you're not folding the time step in, you're not mapping it with that. But they do require sequential time steps to be equal for all okay, that's yeah, that's where we have not worked out. For simpler cases, we can do variable time stamping. But for this with memory, we can't we don't know how to do that yet. So it is a requirement at the moment. Okay. All right. Just Seymour, are you there? Yes, I am. Yeah. Okay. Can you ask me a question directly? So, I had a question regarding just a comparison with other time series forecasting methods. I was curious if the methods that you propose, if they are comparable or better than other conventional time series forecasting methods. And if we have time, I have some other questions about your other papers. But it's probably going to be outside of the scope of this talk. So we didn't do comparison with other tiny. Yeah, there are a lot of statistical methods to do that. We didn't do that can compose? I would guess, look, this kind of thing is hard to get without a method. I think, I don't know I'm not aware of the method can get this kind of accuracy with this little data over this much long time, to be honest. And if you are aware of some please let me know I would be more than interested in looking into those methods. Okay. By the way, I didn't I wasn't aware we didn't do any comparison. So yeah. Thank you very much. All right. Sounds good. phase out. Are you still there? Curious in the fastest. All right, phase out. We heard you. Can you? Podium up? We barely hear you. There is? One, I can just ask. Okay, Faisal asked. In the fastest slow example, the GTA and your ln do not diverse does it imply Lea penal exponent of zero? Which? I do not know, to be honest. Alright. I don't have a good answer for ya. All right. Shawn, are you still there? Sean Smith, from Los Alamos. If you want to ask a question directly. Otherwise, I can ask, he asked. The motivation of this approach is that to use mathematical computational tools to circumvent the necessity for physical modeling, however, definition of the state space that you rely on is a large proportion of the physical modeling, even when provided by experiments. selecting appropriate instruments requires insightful physical understanding. Even when the state space is only partially defined using Mori to draw to Anzick. The selection of the soft set of the state spaces in is even more critical. In each of your examples. The state space was defined by fiscal model, do you have any comment on that convening? And trying to understand so question. If I guess is that about how to select what variable to in order to understand the physics, if that's the case, I think is a slightly different problem, right? It's an important problem. So a question to ask, even for parser to observe what variable I want to observe in order to understand the dynamics of of the problem. And this, the method here is just assuming that's what you observed. So the limited case that whatever I've observed something that completely useless, I see nothing happens. For example, I observe. For a moving vehicle, I observed the vertical location on vehicle which is zero never changes. But this message just said, you've given me that data and we produce a prediction of zero, the vertical location which We'll always be zero. So which is still correct, but the use of these results. So I think these are slightly different problem, if I understand what you asked, clear, so, so identification of the variable to measure. And this is important, but a different equation here is just, if you observe this, we're going to produce predictors, which may be useless if you will observe the use of these variables. I hope I understand the question. Shawn said, Thank you, so. Okay. Sounds like you answer them correctly? Well, I don't see any other question. But I have a couple of questions, you know, when you when you extend your method to the PDE, and you gave the nice examples, and how, you know, gave gave us an insight on how to extend your FM FML method. You know, so you have introduced, you know, you can, you can do so using some linear map, and but why do you stick with a linear map, or, you know, extended to, you know, nonlinear map, using the neural net? On spatial? human motivation? Yeah, exactly. Right. No, no, we didn't use this, we just that this thing exists, it's, let's take this all for less, like, let's say, it's a worst case, a new one that can do, we can UNL would be make everything nonlinear. So it just motivation is how we designed the network structure based on this, because it's just after no less than a few 1000 testing cases, and nothing really worked consistently. We're just trying to find ways to see maybe we need a structure. So we didn't know what to do. So we look into all our forward type of thing. And then we decided, based on this to design your last structure mimicking this. Yeah, exactly. And then you change the D, you know, differentiation matrices to nonlinear, right functions. And by doing so you're effectively introducing the space, which is a lot bigger than just a linear array, it's bigger than that. So it can be a nonlinear map. So in some sense, the training will be harder than it will be more expensive, because we have the block thing. So input output, forget about this later, I think that we have this parallel layers, network layers here, and then this thing goes vertically on component wise So training is, is a little bit more involved is mostly because for PE the vector is much longer. That's actually the killer part. Right? So when I said if I can add in my finishing slide, when I say most of our network, simple small, apply to this, because when we do PDU, Here, input, one stop. For this, we use surgical with one layer of here, because one layer like that, that luck in this thing, it works remarkably well. And in our paper, we actually did two layers simply because I told my student look, if you don't do tell two layers, people will ask why don't you go deep network solar? It just one layer was fine. So the moment it becomes only that works well. Okay, well, I was wanting to ask, you know, there's a sounds like there's a trade off between, you know, you're making the training harder, but in some sense, you're increasing the dimension of the parameter space. So you're hoping that you will get the better model at the end? In principle, we hope that Yeah. So I guess that's the table. You're talking about here? Oh, by the way, the last two slides examples. You said the PDE with a missing variable. You look like a PDE with the missing equations not variable. Well, if the entire missing is a variable, right? This is 2400 v 2500. W, we're missing 25. If you think the entire video has 5000 thing, we are missing half of it. So yeah, it's the missing variable, right. Insert entire PDE equations with the first one. You still have a V and W all of them right? together. So we're just we don't have w here is a model of the only model V only. Okay, this is only for V. There's nothing you we only observe the we don't have W whatsoever. Oh, got it. Oh, okay. I misunderstood this like, Oh, okay. Yeah. All right. Sounds good. Sounds good. I'm sure there are more liquid. More questions. I personally do. But I think I can ask that. If you have interested in this, please feel free to write me email. I'd be more than happy to discuss offline. I mean, online offline to this talk. So I'd be happy to answer any question. They said me explore some possibility to work collaborate as well. So that'll be awesome. Yeah. All right. Thank you so much. Let's, let's thank our speaker today and for the wonderful talk, and as he's done being said, hopefully there's a future collaboration between us. Alright, sounds good. Thank you. Thank you very much. Thank you for the invite. Okay, bye bye.